now that our application logic and our
resources are stored in the app cache
let's talk about how we store data
locally there are several different ways
to store data locally many of which have
developed over time so let's cover each
of these briefly local storage is the
oldest and most basic of the storage ap
is it lets you get and set key value
pairs and iterate through all the keys
however each value is just a string and
each domain can only store a total of
between two and five megabytes and local
storage depending on the browser there's
no real searching capability you can
index through all the keys one at a time
or you can ask for the value associated
with a particular key but that's
basically it the local storage API is
really simple to use take a look at how
you can store an item using set item
retrieve the value for a particular item
with get item you can remove one key
value pair with a remove item iterate
through all the key value pairs with
length key and get item or clear the
entire local storage system